bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur Public
Sénat en septembre dernier la Cour des
comptes remettait un rapport sur la
sécurité sociale et notamment ces
dérapages budgétaires sur l'ensemble du
rapport 25 pages seulement porté sur
l'assurance maternité 25 pages mais qui
remettent en cause le système de fond en
ble l'assurance maternité c'est un
système qui permet aux femmes enceintes
de voir leurs dépenses de santé prise en
charge à 100 % du 6e mois de grossesse
jusqu'au suite de l'accouchement et ce
même si les dépenses ne sont pas
directement liées à la maternité c'est
un système qui est propre à la France
qui est très cher et surtout très
compliqué alors que préconise la Cour
des comptes et bien de revoir de fond en
comble cette assurance maternité elle
est effectivement gérée par l'assurance
maladie mais sans être une branche
autonome de la sécurité sociale bref
vous l'avez vu c'est très compliqué
aujourd'hui je vous propose donc de
revoir l'audition menée hier par la
commission des affaires sociales du
Sénat à ce sujet plusieurs personnalités
ont été auditionné parmi lesquells
Antoine durlement le président de la 6e
chambre de la Cour des comptes tout de
suite direction la salle micis il y a 2
ans madame la Présidente Annie David au
nom de notre commission avait sollicité
la cour des compte afin qu'elle réalise
une enquête sur la situation des
maternités dans notre pays il par en
effet nécessaire de faire le point sur
un secteur en profonde évolution au
cours de ces 15 dernières années et de
chercher à évaluer la pertinence de
notre organisation en terme d'accès aux
soins de qualité de cohérence
réglementaire et de financement il
s'agit pour nos concitoyens et là plus
spécifiquement pour nos
concitoyennes d'un enjeu de santé
publique très important et nous espérons
que cette enquête permettra de dresser
un certain nombre de constats objectifs
puis de réfléchir et de débattre sur des
pistes d'amélioration la Cour a mené un
important travail en impliquant
plusieurs chambres régionales des
comptes ce qui a permis d'affiner les
analyses à travers des enquêtes très
précises menées dans six régions de
métropole et en
Guyane Monsieur Antoine durlement
président de la 6e chambre va nous en
présenter les conclusions
il est accompagné de Noël brick monsieur
Noël diric conseiller maître ainsi que
de Madame an Anne Christine priosé et
Monsieur SAB Salah premier conseiller de
chambre régionale des comptes je laisse
la parole à Monsieur
durlement monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les
Sénateurs la convention en
1795 a créé à Paris sur le site de
bodelock et de Port Royal l'hospice de
la maternité ce fut le début
de d'un changement profond qui vit
progressivement les naissances d'un
notre pays se concentrer dans les
établissements de santé ce mouvement
s'est achevé à la fin des années 1960
aujourd'hui les 820000 naissances qui
ont été constatées en 2000 14 ce sont
pour la quasittalité euh concentré dans
des
maternités vous nous avez demandé
d'examiner la situation du réseau des
maternités dans notre pays à partir
essentiellement de constat de terrain
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
conduit avec les six chambre régionale
des comptes qui nous ont rejoint une
enquête pendant 14 mois à la fois au
niveau local en étudiant la situation et
l'organisation de 19 établissements de
santé en examinant l'organisation et le
maillage des maternités plus
particulièrement dans cette région de
notre pays et enfin naturellement en
conduisant une enquête au niveau
national visant à synthétiser les
éléments d'appréciation dont les
administrations centrales pouvaient
disposé ce sont les conclusions de cette
enquête que nous vous avons proposé sous
forme de deux volets une analyse
générale une série de monographies
régionales consacrées à une approche
plus particulière dans cette région
quels sont à ce stade nos constats et
quelles sont nos
propositions notre premier constat c'est
celui d'une restructuration considérable
du réseau des maternités restructuration
guidée prioritairement par des
considérations de sécurité de la
naissance et d'amélioration des
indicateurs de
périnatalité ce mouvement a commencé au
début des années
1970 avec la parution de ce qu'on
appelle le décret dienche il s'est
accéléré surtout avec lapparution des
décrets du 9 octobre
1998 qui ont visé dans le prolongement
du plan périnatalité de
1994 à améliorer substantiellement les
indicateurs de périnatalité de notre
pays dont il était considéré qu'il
pouvait substantiellement
s'améliorer le premier constat c'est que
cette restructuration a été la plus
profonde qu'a connu le secteur
hospitalier dans notre pays au cours des
années récentes de 1900
172 à 2012 ce sont les 2 tiers des
maternités qui ont été formé qui ont été
fermé
de
1998 à
2012 le nombre de maternité s'est encore
diminué de manière substantielle avec en
2012 544 maternités dans notre
pays ce mouvement de restructuration
extrêmement
profonde a eu pour conséquence une
diminution très importante du nombre
d'établissement je le soulignis mais
également une diminution très importante
du nombre de lit de d'obstétrique dans
notre
pays cette diminution très substantielle
c'est'est traduite par une
augmentation de la dimension moyenne des
établissements avec au cours de la
période
2002-2012 une très forte augmentation
des maternités de grande taille le
nombre de maternités faisant
respectivement plus de 3000 et plus de
4000 accouchements a
considérablement augmenté le nombre
d'accouchements dans les maternités de
plus de 3000 accouchements a doublé en
10 ans alors que le nombre
d'accouchements réalisés dans celle de
moins de 500 accouchement a diminué de
moitié
cette organisation qui s'est donc
puissemment restructuré apparaît
cependant aboutir à un paysage des
maternités qui est assez
substantiellement différent dans notre
pays de celui que l'on constate dans un
certain nombre de nos euh
voisin quand on regarde la situation
d'un pays comme la Suède les maternité
de plus de 3000 accouchements représente
51 % des
accouchements les accouchements réalisés
dans des maternités de plus de 3000
habitants de plus de 3000 accouchements
représente 69 % des accouchements en
Grande-Bretagne ce taux dans notre pays
est aujourd'hui de 23
%. ce
mouvement qui a
donc eu pour conséquence la fermeture
accélérée des plus petites maternités
l'augmentation corrélative de la taille
des
maternités les plus importantes a
également eu des effets sur la
répartition des établissements entre les
secteurs entre le secteur pu public
entre les établissements de santé privés
d'intérêt collectif et les
établissements de santé abus lucratif il
y a eu une déformation de la structure
des maternités du point de vue de leur
de leur statut en
particulier la réorganisation de ces
dernières années s'est traduite par une
forte diminution du nombre et de la part
que représente les établissements privés
abus lucratif en 2002 il représentait
1/ers des accouchements il n' représente
plus qu'un/art en
2012 en revanche et corrélativement la
part du secteur public a augmenté quand
la part des établissements de santé
privé d'intérêt collectif euh à elle
est-elle resté stable
cette
évolution se traduit par un certain
nombre de conséquences la première
conséquence c'est que il est difficile
de ne pas la corréler avec la tendance à
l'augmentation des soins techniques dans
l'accouchement cette ce mouvement est
très sensible il est très prononcé il
est documenté il se
traduit en sens inverse par le sentiment
de beaucoup de femmes que devant un
accouchement qui devient de plus en plus
technique il y a le souhait de revenir à
un rythme plus naturel à des
accouchements d'avantage physiologique
et cela se traduit par des choix de lieu
de naissance de la part d'un certain
nombre de femmes qui choisissent d'aller
dans certains établissements plutôt que
dans d'Ar d'autres deuxème conséquence
de cette évolution extrêmement profonde
cela a été la
nécessité de mettre en place des
structures spécifiques destinées à
permettre un suivi de proximité des
femmes sous deux formes la création de
réseau de santé périnatal aujourd'hui au
nombre de 55 dans notre pay
et d'autre part la création de centres
périnataux de proximité aujourd'hui au
nombre de 68 dans notre
pays la mise en place de ces dispositifs
spécifiques apparaît comme des facteurs
importants de
facilitation de la restructuration de la
réorganisation des maternité permettant
d'assurer sur certains types d'actes en
particulier les consultations pré
postnatales la réalisation de
consultations d'échographie insuivie de
proximité alors que l'accouchement
lui-même se situe dans des
établissements dont le maillage est
moins dense qu'il n'était dans le passé
ce maillage moins dense ne s'est
pourtant pas traduit par une
augmentation des durées d'accès au lieu
de naissance c'est-à-dire au Matern
elle-même sur les 10 dernières années le
temps médian d'accès aux maternités est
resté stable à 17 minutes même si l'on
constate évidemment dans certains
départements des temps d'accès qui sont
plus importants plusieurs cartes dans le
rapport montrent ces différents
aspects on peut ainsi considérer que ce
mouvement de restruct
tion aboutit aujourd'hui à un paysage
qui
paraît à la fois répondre aux objectifs
qui étaient ceux des initiateurs des
décrets de
1998 et rencontrer un équilibre au
regard des besoins de desserte de la
population ce constat cet état des lieux
est cependant faussement urant et c'est
notre deuxème constat notre constat
c'est que malgré cette
restructuration extrêmement profonde
cette
réorganisation malgré les outils qui ont
été mis en place la sécurité de la
naissance reste aujourd'hui dans un
certain nombre de situations
imparfait il nous apparaît en effet au
terme de notre enquête que les décrets
de
1998 restent aujourd'hui 16 ans après
leur
parution très imparfaitement respecté
d'abord en ce qui concerne la
problématique des
effectifs nous constatons une situation
paradoxale celle de professionnels de
santé pour les professions qui
intéressent directement la naissance
c'est-à-dire les gynécologues
obstétriciens les anesthésistes
réanimateurs et les pédiatres en
particulier et bien évidemment les
sages-femmes celle d'une situation
démographique de ces profession de la
naissance qui n'a jamais été aussi élevé
et malgré tout nous constatons à la fois
des inégalités de répartition
territoriale extrêmement prononcé et
surtout le fait que dans les années qui
viennent les évolutions démographiques
de ces professions vont V conduire à des
fragilités et à des
fragilisations encore
accru cela pour plusieurs raisons d'une
part parce que les professions de santé
médicale hors sage-femme ne sont dém
démographiquement aussi forte que parce
que elle concentre plus que les autres
spécialités médicales les apport de
médecins à diplôme étrangers évidemment
la question se pose de savoir si ces
flux qui se dirigent vers notre pays de
médecins à diplôme étranger peuvent
continuer à être dans les années qui
viennent au rythme que nous avons
constaté dans les dernières années mais
aussi parce que les flux de formation de
notre pays lui-même même s'ils ont
augmenté ont augmenté moins pour ces
professions que pour les autres
spécialités
médicales notre constat c'est donc celui
du d'une fragilité qui est déjà marquée
pour certains établissements dans
certains territoires qu'il s'agisse des
territoires ruraux les plus isolés qu'il
s'agisse de territoires urbains situés
dans des contextes populationnels
défavorisés mais ce que nous anticipons
c'est une dégradation rapide et
considérablement accru de la démographie
de ces professions
de
santé de ce point de vuelà nous relevons
que en l'état actuel des choses
l'ensemble des établissements ne
respecte pas les normes de personnel et
en particulier les impératifs en terme
de permanence des soins qui leur sont
opposés et qui leur sont imposés par les
décrets de
1998 nous documentons dans le rapport le
fait que les normes de personnel ne sont
pas
systématiquement respectés dans les
maternités quels que soient les efforts
déployés par les établissement qu'il
s'agisse du recrutement de médecins
contractuels qu'il s'agisse du
recrutement de médecins intérimaire
qu'il s'agisse de l'appel accru à des
femme chacun le sait chacun le constate
et la fermeture brutale de la maternité
d'orèse au mois d'octobre dernier à la
suite d'un
accident grave en
constate en témoine plus exactement il y
a des fragilités considérables et dans
un certain nombre de cas des risques des
risques
importants notre deè at au regard de la
sécurité des des prises en charge c'est
que les fragilités ne sont pas
simplement d'ordre démographique au
regard des professions de la naissance
des difficultés importantes se
constatent également dans d'autres
domaines c'est d'abord la problématique
de l'organisation des locaux les décrets
de 1998 sont très prescriptif en ce qui
concerne l'organisation du secteur de la
naissance en prévoyant en particulier la
nécessité euh d'une contiguité autant
que possible entre le bloc obstétrical
et le secteur de la naissance au moins
le fait que euh bloc obstétrical et
secteur de la naissance soit dans le
même bâtiment ça n'est pas euh
systématiquement le cas et il arrive
même que dans un certain nombre de
réorganisation récente nous donnons
l'exemple du CHU de tour nous constas un
certain nombre de difficultés 2è point
de
fragilité il s'intéresse aux conditions
de fonctionnement de certains
établissements nous avons regardé de
manière très particulière très attentive
les modalités de fonctionnement des plus
petites maternités c'est-à-dire des
maternités de moins de 300 accouchements
le nombre de 300 accouchements
euh
euh étant en principe euh le seuil à
partir duquel une maternité peut-être
autorisée à fonctionner elle ne peut
être autorisée à fonctionner euh avec
moins de 300 accouchements qu'à titre
dérogatoire il existe actuellement dans
notre pays 13 maternités euh qui
fonctionnent avec moins de 300
accouchement euh à titre dérogatoire
nous avons constaté dans un certain
nombre de cas que euh il existait des
situations de non conformité aux règles
de fonctionnement qui nous apparaissent
particulièrement préoccupant nous
documentons en particulier dans le
rapport la situation de la maternité de
10 qui a réalisé 137
accouchements et qui continue à
fonctionner malgré des difficultés qui
ont été relevées euh par l'agence
régionale de de de
santé cette fragilité à la fois
démographique
organisationnelle se double de
difficultés au regard de la
structuration même des prises en charge
au regard des difficultés prévisibles
que peuvent rencontrer les
enfants la structuration des maternités
par niveau niveau 1 pour des grossesses
normales non pathologique niveau 2 pour
des grossesses pour lequel on anticipe
le besoin de soins pour les nourrissons
à naître niveau 3 pour des grossesses
dites pathologiques soit au regard de la
merre soit au regard de l'enfant cette
structuration entre maternité de niveau
1 maternité de niveau 2 maternité de
niveau 3 apparaît de plus en plus
déformé historiquement au moment de la
mise en place des de
1998 bien évidemment les euh indications
de niveau ont été décidé en fonction de
l'existant mais la restructuration
accélérée des 10 dernières années a
conduit à déformer encore davantage les
structures de prise en charge la
diminution très importante des
maternités de niveau 1 a pour
conséquence une concentration des
naissances dans les maternités de niveau
2 et dans les maternités niveau 3 avec
dans un certain nombre de cas notamment
s'agissant des maternités niveau 3 une
difficulté d'accès pour les grossesses
pathologiques parce que les maternités
de niveau 3 accueillent un très grand
nombre évidemment de grossesse non
pathologique nous documentons ces
difficultés nous montrons en
particulier les difficultés de bonne
orientation malgré réaction des réseaux
de santé PARINAT
périnatal des naissances gémellaires et
des
naissances et des naissances
prématurées enfin c'est le trème point
de fragilité de notre
organisation des maternités nous
constatons un certain nombre de points
de vigilance qui de notre point de vue
ne sont pas encore suffisamment pris en
compte ces points de vigilance sont au
nombre de 3 d'abord nous avons constaté
la situation préoccupante d'un certain
nombre d'établissements au regard des
indicateurs de
périnatalité nous constatons que un
certain nombre d'établissements
connaissent des indicateurs de
périnatalité extrêmement dégradés par
rapport à la moyenne
euh euh dans
euh 33
maternités le taux d'enfants Mornés est
près du double de la
moyenne dans 20 maternités ce taux
de d'enfant Mornés dépasse 10 % dans
certaines maternités il atteint de 15 à
20 pour pour
1000 il n'y a pas pour autant d'analyse
systématique de ces
situations 2è 2è point de préoccupation
c'est le mauvais suivi des populations
en situation de précarité nous avons
constaté beaucoup d'initiatives
intéressante pour
accompagner des populations en situation
de précarité avec en particulier le
recours à des réseaux associatifs mais
force de constater la cour l'avait
d'ailleurs déjà souligné dans son
rapport public annuel il y a 2 ans que
la situation des populations précaires
reste un point de difficulté enfin nous
avons regardé de manière plus
particulière puisque c'était monsieur le
Président une des demandes de votre
commission la situation de la prise en
charge de la naissance dans les
départements
d'outremer nous avions documenté cette
situation dans le rapport public
thématique que nous avons publié en mai
2014 pour constater la situation
globalement difficile dans les
départements
d'outremer avec évidemment un point de
très grande attention en ce qui concerne
la Guyane et la situation à Mayotte où
pour de multiples raisons les
indicateurs de périnatalité sont
particulièrement
dégradés face à cette situation d'un
mouvement de restructuration extrêmement
profond mais en même temps de fragilité
encore très importante notre constat
c'est que dans les années qui viennent
le mouvement de réorganisation de
restructuration des maternités va encore
samplifier il va
s'amplifier à la fois pour ses raisons
de démographie pour ses raisons
organisationnelles mais également pour
des raisons d'ordre
d'ficience quand nous avons avons étudié
la situation financière des
maternités nous avons été frappés par
l'extrême fragilité financière des
maternités qu'il s'agisse des maternités
publiques ou qu'il s'agisse des
maternités privées qui sont soumises à
un effet de ciseau entre des charges qui
augmentent et des tarification qui reste
très largement fondé sur une base
historique malgré revalorisations
récentes cet effet de ciseau fragilise
l'ensemble du réseau des maternités tant
public que privé pour le public nous
l'avons assez bien documenté pour le
privé nous n'avons pas été en situation
de le documenter puisque vous le savez
nous n'avons pas accès aux données
financières des établissements privés de
santé abus lucratif et nous n'avons pas
obtenu de la part des cliniques privées
auxquelles nous nous sommes adressés des
éléments permettant de connaître la
réalité de leur situation financière
au-delà évidemment des éléments d'ordre
très général que nous a apporté la
fédération de
l'hospitalisation privé cette
fragilisation
financière des maternités pose en tout
état de cût en tout état de cause la
question de l'évolution de leur
tarification cette évolution de la
tarification doit néanmoins prendre en
compte le fait que l'efficience même des
maternités doit être questionné au
regard de deux indicateurs le premier
indicateur c'est la durée moyenne de
séjour qui reste dans notre pays
beaucoup plus importante que chez nos
voisins
42 jours aujourd'hui de durée moyenne de
séjour dans les maternités de notre pays
contre tris en moyenne dans les pays de
l'OCDE et deuxième indicateur qui montre
aussi que
l'efficience n'est pas toujours optimale
c'est le taux d'occupation des lit
malgré la très forte diminution du
nombre de lit que je signalais au début
de mon exposé le taux d'occupation des
lit reste aujourd'hui médiocre
puisque nombre de services que
iss une occupation très inférieure à ce
qui serait à ce qui serait
souhaitable cette situation de
fragilité
amène dans les années qui viennent à
anticiper des fermetures supplémentaires
de
maternité nous avons de ce point de vue
là chercher à analyser la vision que
pouvait avoir l'administr tion
centrale de
l'évolution du réseau des maternités
dans notre pays nous avons été très
frappé de voir que l'administration
centrale n'avait pas finalement de
vision à 10 ans ou à 15 ans de
l'organisation du réseau des maternités
dans notre pays et de la structuration
souhaitable de l'organisation des
maternités dans notre dans notre dans
notre pays et nous avons eu le sentiment
qu'il y avait de la part de
l'administration centrale euh une sorte
de défausse sur les agences régionales
de santé à charge pour elle chacune sur
leur territoire de chercher à organiser
au mieux euh en fonction des stratégies
d'établissement qui souvent euh sont
inégalement maîtrisé par les agences la
recomposition du paysage des maternités
nous avons été frappés de voir que de ce
point de vue-là
euh la stabilité qui est souvent allégué
du réseau des maternités dans les années
qui viennent ne se traduisait pas par
les fourchettes qu'indiquaient les
agences régionales de santé dans leur
Soss puisque les agences régionales de
santé dans les Soss qui sont en cours
d'exécution anti typ de -1 à - 47
maternités dans les années qui viennent
évidemment la diminution d'une
maternité ne changerait pas
substantiellement la
situation du réseau des
maternités la diminution de 47
maternités voudrait dire que dans les
années qui viennent il y aurait une
contraction de l'offre de 10 % ce qui
est considérable et cette diminution de
l'offre serait en particulier concentrée
dans certaines dans certaines région ce
qui nous est apparu de ce point de vue
là c'est que le risque était celui d'une
sorte de recomposition sauvage à la
suite d'une série de décisions
individuelles des établissements en
particulier des établissements privés
qui sont potentiellement plus petit que
les établissements publics qui
apparaissent quelquefois davantage
fragilisés par des stratégies
d'établissement qui amènent aujourd'hui
les groupes privés à considérer que ils
ne sont plus prêt à supporter les
déficits de ces maternités qu'ils ont
supporté longtemps en considérant que
accueillir une naissance c'était
accueillir une famille et que dans le
temps il y avait un flux de patientel
qui s'orienteraiit vers elle aujourd'hui
les stratégies des établissements privés
intégrés dans des groupes puissants font
que elle les les les établissements
n'hésitent plus à se désengager
quelquefois brutalement d'activités non
non non
Renta l'ensemble de ces considédération
nous amène à souligner donc le risque
d'une recomposition au coup par coup
très souvent lié à des risques
d'accident qui ne pourraient être paliés
ou à des accidents avérés avec pour
conséquence un réseau des maternité qui
dans les années à venir serait encore
plus en difficulté qu'aujourd'hui au
regard de la desserte de la population
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
appelons à une réflexion d'ordre général
sur les objectifs aujourd'hui de la
recomposition du système de maternité il
nous apparaît que de même qu'il y a eu
au début des années 90 une réflexion
large et générale euh
ouverte sur l'ensemble des parties
prenantes sur les objectifs de
recomposition de nos maternités il nous
apparaît aujourd'hui qu'une réflexion du
même type est tout à fait
indispensable pour piloter activement
des réorganisations qui sont aussi
nécessaires
qu'inélctable nous formulons de ce point
de vuelà au total
neuf
propositions pour aider au pilotage d'un
secteur très activement recomposé mais
qui encore aujourd'hui doit se poser la
question de sa structuration pour les
années qui viennent merci monsieur le
Président je vais d'abord laisser la
parole faire réagir d'abord la FF
ensuite les ARS puis après je vous
donnerai la parole monsieur caher je
vous laisse réagir monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les
sénateur d'abord je voudrais saluer le
le rapport et la présentation qu'en a
fait monsieur durleman pour la Cour des
comptes ce rapport nous semble-t-il
traduit manière à la fois très étayée
très documentée et et très approfondie
la réalité de la situation du secteur
donc je ne vais pas ni paraphraser ni
commenter ce que ce qui vient d'être
très bien formulé et seulement pour ce
qui concerne la la
partie nous ne sommes pas il y a
d'autres intervenants dans le secteur
qui sont malheureusement
absents mais pour la partie publique qui
représente à peu près les 2 tiers de
l'offre et un peu plus même près 70 % de
l'offre au niveau national faire
quelques remarques et observations qui
vont dans le sens de toute façon des
préconisations de la cour qui nous
paraissent globalement doirêtre
suivi
d'abord souligner le mouvement de
restructuration qui cela a été dit a été
à la fois très important qui a impliqué
de manière massive les professionnels et
les établissements ce travail a été fait
ça n pas été
simple mais en même temps effectivement
il y a une dimension pour le secteur
public de pilotage de ce de cette
évolution et et de de de de constat que
cette évolution est quelque part subie
effectivement il y a un désengagement
pour les raisons à la fois économiqu et
stratégiqu d'un certain nombre d'acteurs
privés qui a été fort bien expliqué qui
traduit la nécessité pour le secteur
public de prendre en char charge ce qui
est sa vocation et sa mission dans le
cadre du service public ce secteur de la
maternité et des accouchements et la
petite
enfance ce développement s'est
accompagné il est vrai d'un
glissement expliqué par des des raisons
structurelles vers plus de technicité
vers une plus grande taille des
établissements avec des problématiques
de d'organisation et de gestion qui ne
sont pas toutes réglées don je pense que
ce travail doit être fait NOTAM sur
l'articulation et ça a été très bien
expliqué dans le rapport entre les
niveaux 1 2 et 3 les réseaux de manière
à ce que l'articulation de la prise en
charge des des parturiantes et de leur
de leur nouveauné mais des familles
aussi soit fait dans les meilleures
conditions ce qui n'est pas toujours le
cas la préoccupation portée sur deuxè
sujet sur les inégalité d'accès sur les
territoires qui doivent
re éré par le fait que l'accès moyen et
le temps moyen d'accès reste correct
pour l'ensemble du pays il y a des zones
difficiles des zones qui vont
effectivement demain et ça les ARS
pourront le témoigner aussi pourront en
témoigner aussi des zones qui demain
seront peut-être plus problématique en
lien avec les problèmes de démographie
professionnelle ce sujet doit doit nous
interroger çaela a été dit je viens d'en
parler le problème majeur nous
semble-t-il enfin l'un des problèmes
majeurs c'est la question du maintien de
l'attractivité et de l'organisation de
l'attractivité pour les professionnels
qui soi médicaux ou sag-femm et
paramédicaux dans ce secteur la
situation est particulièrement
problématique depuis nombre d'années
elle va certainement cela a aussi été
dit
s'aggraver il y a actuellement un
rapport qui qui a été confié à Monsieur
Leen sur la question de l'attractivité
auquel nous sommes particulièrement
attentif Jacky Len étant un ancien
sénateire aussi membre de cette
commission je crois euh donc cette cette
question nous préoccupe énormément à la
FHF nous aurons besoin de l'ensemble de
ces réflexions et des des contributions
et des appuis pour y contribuer il est
exact que le décret de 98 n'a pas été
mise en œuvre dans toutes ces dimensions
le rapport met et pointe et met bien en
évidence un certain nombre de
d'insuffisance et d'inapplication
notamment en terme de locaux
d'équipement de personnel aussi sur ce
décret cela doit nous interroger en
terme d'organisation et de planification
le mot peut-être peut-il encore être
proféré en tout cas le rapport préconise
la mise en place de vision et d'un
schéma à moyen terme qui articule mieux
les niveaux et les organisations nous ne
pouvons que faire notre cette ce souhait
et cette
obligation la situation des petits
établissements qui est particulièrement
soulignée dans dans dans toute son
acuité dans le rapport est évidemment un
sujet de préoccupation il n'est pas il
ne peut-être dissocié de la question de
l'aménagement du territoire et les
préoccupations de politique locale il
faut le dire donc un certain nombre de
situations qui perdurent euh dans ce
pays de de manière constante continue
malgré éventuellement nos préconisations
en terme technique faut le dire donc il
ne s'agit pas de s'opposer à ce
niveau-là donc la préconisation de faire
une analyse
épidémiologique détaillé et d'évaluer
les situations nous paraît une bonne
voie de de progrès en ce qui concerne
les les évolutions que que vous
formuliez monsieur le Président
d'urleman sur l'organisation des
établissements après concertation avec
les professionnels je peux confirmer que
l'évolution des durées de séjour dans
les établissements public est considéré
comme non seulement faisable mais
souhaitable euh si c'est C durée de
séjour demeure élevée c'est
essentiellement parce que les
professionnels jusqu'à présent ont
considéré qu'elle devait rester à ce
niveau-là mais il ne semble pas que ce
soit une question infranchissable et les
les concertations qu'on a pu avoir don à
penser qu'on peut évoluer positivement
sur ce ce terrainlà en tout cas la FHF
peut y contribuer Enfin les taux
d'occupation oui j'oublierai pas ce
sujet de la précarité j'allais terminer
là-dessus les taux d'occupation doivent
être revus et on a proposé avec le la
naap un travail enfin l'Agence nationale
pour l'amélioration de la performance un
travail sur cette
question la la problématique de de la
durée de séjour ne peut pas être
dissociée je terminerai là-dessus même
si ce n'est pas un sujet tout à fait
anodin sur la question de la gestion de
l'aval et de la
précarité il est clair que ce pays
connaît actuellement une situation
économique qui n'aura échappé à personne
cette situation économique a une
traduction en terme de difficulté pour
les les futures mamans et leur famille
et que dans le contexte il est
extrêmement difficile et dans certaines
situations de plus en plus compliqué
d'accompagner l'accouchement et surtout
les suites de l'accouchement donc c'est
une situation qui demande une réflexion
une organisation et à l'évidence puisque
c'est ce que nous avons entendu une
relance d'une réflexion de nature
politique et et de santé publique sur ce
secteur nous en sommes tout à fait
d'accord et la FHF en tout cas est prête
à accompagner le mouvement
merci les ARS maintenant madame Aoustin
peut-être d'abord et puis monsieur
lanelong ensuite ou Monsieur lanelongue
Madame Aoustin vous choisissez on va
faire monsieur le Président une
intervention à deux voix monsieur le
Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le Président de la 6e chambre
madame et Messieurs les magistrats euh
je voudrais voudrais d'abord
effectivement vous remercier et
remercier aussi la cour et les Chambres
régionales car ce travail est
effectivement euh extrêmement
approfondie et constitue une mise en
perspective euh très importante d'une
politique publique euh qui a été engagée
de très long très longue date euh avec
un engagement euh des pouvoirs publics
dans toutes leurs composantes et euh il
me semble que euh un des points majeurs
que que fait apparaître le rapport c'est
au fond l'ampleur des efforts
d'organisation des soins qui ont été
conduits par les ARH puis les
ARS et de ce point de vue c'est pour
nous un premier enseignement qui est la
capacité de la puissance publique à
promouvoir des améliorations
significatives dans l'organisation des
soins et je dis ça par rapport à des
visions qui tendrai à considérer que
finalement seuls les actions de marché
par les prix ou les actions on va dirait
de portée nationale normative sont
efficaces on a la démonstration que sur
longue période l'action d'organisation
des soins en proximité des acteurs à
travers des mécanismes de planification
d'incitation territorial on va dire
euh peuvent faire la preuve de leur
efficacité le rapport de ce point de
vue-là est très enrichissant sur toutes
les
initiatives qui ont été prises par les
ARH puis les ARS et c'est au fond une
espèce de collection de bonnes pratique
qui m'est apparu tout à fait
passionnante sur ce qui a été fait et ce
qui doit être développé encore plus à
l'avenir alors euh au-delà donc
de ces aspects on va dire
positifs c'est vrai le rapport fait
apparaître la nécessité de poursuivre
des des progrès dans ce domaine je
parlerai des questions d'organisation et
et ma collègue parlera des questions de
financement et de qualité de sécurité
sur les questions
d'organisation on ne peut oui j'aurais
dû commencer par dire que naturellement
euh la ministre euh euh bah prendra en
compte les préconisations les constats
et préconisation du rapport et que donc
nous réagissons à
chaud à partir de ces constats et
préconisations du rapport
mais bien entendu ce rapport mérite une
prise en compte globale par le ministère
de la santé de tous ces aspect je
reviens aux questions d'organisation
c'est vrai que on ne peut être que
d'accord avec avec les préconisations du
rapport sur la nécessité de poursuivre
une réflexion
prospective d'organiser cette réflexion
dans une
programmation parce que comme le
soulligne fort justement le
rapport nous sommes soumis à des
pressions
contradictoires celle des exigences de
qualité de sécurité celle aussi du
respect d'un
minimum de de temps d'accès
celle de des questions
d'attractivité des pour les
professionnels celle de l'aménagement du
territoire de la place que représentent
ces
établissement
pour les collectivités
concerné et au
fond on ne peut gérer dans la durée et
d'une manière
rationnelle l'ensemble de ces
préoccupations potentiellement
contradictoires euh qu'à partir d'une
vision réfléchie et muûrie euh je
voudrais insister sur l'importance euh
de la coopération et de la mise en
réseau euh entre les établissements et
aussi entre les acteurs de l'hôpital et
de la médecine de ville euh il n'y a pas
de possibilité de développement de
qualité pour desétablissements isolés il
n'y a pas de possibilité d'amélioration
de la prise en charge euh si euh il n'y
a pas une amélioration de la relation
entre lesissements hospitaliers et leur
environnement de
ville c'est pourquoi la cour et les
chambres gales ont justement
souligner l'importance des travaux
coopératifs des communautés Hospitales
de territoire des relations entre un
hôpital et le CHU pour le renforcement
des ressources médicales le la nécessité
de développer des filières de formation
qui soi des filières de formation avec
une un passage territorial euh la
nécessité euh pour euh euh organiser la
coopération de bien faire fonctionner
les réseaux périnatalité euh je remercie
d'ailleurs tout particulèrement la cour
et les chambresonales d'avoir souligné
euh l'importance et l'efficacité du
réseau périnatalité en Bourgogne qui de
mon point de vue fonctionne d'une
manière exemplaire euh pour faire en
sorte que l'accès de toutes les
parturiantes se fasse dans des
conditions organisées préparées et non
pas euh dans euh on ve dire au fil de
l'eau donc de ce point de vue et je
m'arrêterai là sur les questions
d'organisation il y a certainement la
nécessité à partir de ces considérations
de
renouveler les les schémas je voudrais
insister sur l'aspect filière de
formation le le principal défi et ça a
été rappelé par Monsieur Caillet auquel
nous faisons face aujourd'hui et qui
explique beaucoup de décision prise en
urgence sous contrainte et dans des
conditions dont la Cour a raison de dire
qu'elles ne sont pas satisfaisantes le
principal problème auquel nous faisons
face c'est bien celui de la nécessité
d'avoir des professionnels au bon
endroit au bon moment et ce défi il est
je dirais très franchement il ne peut
pas être résolu d'une manière simple et
immédiate il suppose dans chaque
université dans chaque CHU en liaison
avec que tous les hôpitaux publics d'une
région et privé bien sûr une réflexion
prospective sur les besoins les
évolutions les conditions de formation
la manière dont on peut intéresser des
professionnels à faire carrière à tel ou
tel endroit ça c'est un défi qui doit
être pris en compte dans les travaux
qu'appelle la cour sur une nouvelle
étape de
planification monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les sénateur
monsieur le Président de la
6e cours et mesdames et messieurs les
membres des des cours régionales
mesdames et messieurs oui quelques
points si vous le voulez bien sur deux
sujets en dans dans la suite des propos
de Christophe lanlong un premier point
sur les sujets de sécurité pourquoi
parce que ce qui est frappant dans dans
dans cet excellent rapport je dois dire
euh est que les indicates
qui sont aujourd'hui des indicateurs de
qualité de la périnatalité d'une manière
générale ne sont pas à la hauteur de ce
que nous pourrions attendre en comparant
ces indicateurs aux pays qui sont
aujourd'hui ceux les plus en avance dans
ce domaine et notamment la mortalité
maternelle qui stagne et effectivement
peut-être pourrions-nous avoir des
indicateurs notamment sur la morb
mortalité pour l'enfant un peu amélioré
et donc il y a sans doute lieu de se
poser la question effectivement et et la
l'étude le propose d'une enquête
épidémiologique pour savoir quels sont
les ressorts de ces éléments de ces
indicateurs certains bien évidemment
sont mis sont mis en exerg dans ce
rapport il s'agit vraisemblablement des
éléments organis tionnelle il s'agit
sans doute de
spécificités populationnelles on parle
des conditions de l'accouchement on
parle des conditions post- accouchement
on parle bien sûr des spécificités pour
les populations précaire et moi je
voudrais également insister sur l'avance
l'amont de l'accouchement c'est-à-dire
sur le suivi de la grossesse et
notamment sur l'ensemble des
polypathologies qui apparaissent dans
certaines populations avec une
insuffisance de suivi et nous avons
encore des femmes qui se présentent
d'emblé dans les maternités ça existe
encore même avec la qualité de nos
réseaux périnatalité notamment dans les
domaines et dans les endroits où ces
populations sont socio-économiquement
les plus précaires et donc je pense que
il serait très très important
effectivement que cette étude
épidémiologique mette le point sur là où
le suj je mérite d'être d'être examiné
tout simplement parce que et bien d'un
côté il y a de la prévention de l'autre
côté bref nous n'avons pas forcément les
mêmes choses à mettre en œuvre à chaque
niveau et il est donc important de
spécifier me semble-t-il là où il y a
des difficultés et quelle est la réponse
possible ça n'est pas systématiquement
une réponse établissement de santé bien
évidemment l'autre point que que je
voudrais mettre en exerg et qui est
assez et qui est mis d'ailleurs fort
bien à propos dans ce rapport est la
contradiction apparente entre d'une part
le la technicité toujours plus
importante dans le cadre de la maternité
notamment de l'accouchement et
parallèlement la demande de plus en plus
fréquente également de l'accouchement
physiologique à l'ENV euh des maisons de
naissance ou des centres de proximité et
donc on a là une sorte de contradiction
effectivement qui d'un côté tire vers
les maternités de type 3 et que de qui
de l'autre côté tire également vers des
accouchements dans des conditions
beaucoup plus souples beaucoup plus
légères au plan technique et donc il
serait intéressant là aussi d'avoir un
examen de part mais le le rapport le dit
également fort bien pour savoir est-ce
qu'en fin de compte les difficultés que
nous rencontrons de quelle nature
sont-elles ça rejoint un petit peu euh
ce que j'évoquais précédemment
c'est-à-dire d'avoir un véritable
euh un véritable examen et pourquoi pas
un retour d'expérience sur chacune de
ces de de ces manières d'exercer euh
l'accouchement ou d'exercer globalement
la prise en charge de la grossesse parce
que euh et bien on on va être amené
effectivement dans un examen plus
général que tout un chacun souhaite à se
poser la question d'une orientation
faut-il aller vers une orientation plus
souple et plus légère de la la prise en
charge de la grossesse notamment au au
moment de l'accouchement ou faut-il
inversement et bien se poser la question
d'augmenter le nombre de pédiatres
d'augmenter le nombre dans des
maternités dans lesquelles nous avons
malgré tout des enfants notamment pour
les maternités de type 1 qui sont de
même nature que des enfants qui sont qui
naissent aujourd'hui dans des conditions
plus physiologiques bref je pense que il
y a sur cette contradiction et et sur le
rendu que nous aurons à faire à
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens un retour
d'expérience me semble-t-il
important l'autre l'autre élément qui a
fort bien été analysé également sur et
je quitte là le domaine de la sécurité
et mais en même temps il est il est
également partie prenante euh je
voudrais pardonnez-moi j'avais un mot à
dire également dans le rapport est
évoqué le sujet
Prado et je crois qu'en fait cette
évolution donc
cette prise en charge post post
accouchement peut effectivement avec un
soutien à domicile encore une fois pour
autant que l'ensemble des populations et
celles qui en ont le plus besoin
c'est-à-dire en général les populations
les plus précaires puissent y accéder ou
a envie d'y accéder ou participe à cet
accès et bien est sans doute une
orientation importante en poste
accouchement je reviens si vous le
voulez bien sur le deuxième sujet que
que nous avions décidé de de vous
présenté et donc par ma bouche qui est
le sujet des éléments de financement et
qui de ce fait bien
entendu font que certaines maternités ne
sont pas en situation ou du moins font
des choix qui sont des choix de limiter
le nombre de personnel entourant
l'activité
d'accouchement bien entendu euh il y a
également en matière de financement mais
cela vient d'être dit par monsieur le
président
le les maternités privées depuis fort
longtemps abandonnent l'activité
d'accouchement elles ont maintenu cette
activité au maximum car c'est tout à
fait exact cela correspondait pour elle
à une forme d'attractivité et notamment
pour les maternités qui étaient des
maternités un peu d'arrière-pays ou des
maternités inscrites dans des
territoires dans des territoires plus
ruraux ou périurbains mais forçit de
constater que elles ont abandonné cette
activité évidemment pour des motifs qui
sont des motifs économiques et
financiers à la fois lié à une
normalisation nécessaire mais
semble-t-il trop onéreuse par rapport au
tarifs et ce n'est pas uniquement depuis
la T2A évidemment c'est bien antérieur
puisque depuis 2002 et régulièrement et
même bien avant d'ailleurs il y a eu une
il y a eu effectivement une perte de lit
privé dans ce domaine la région
langdocrousillon reste encore une région
dans laquelle du fait du très fort taux
d'hospitalisation privée sur l'ensemble
de l'activité quelle qu'en soit la
nature MCO nous avons encore presque 50
% des accouchements qui sont réalisés
dans le secteur privé mais il faut
reconnaître que là aussi ça n'est pas
pour une rentabilité économique mais
c'est pour absorber également l'ensemble
de la activité qui va de paire
l'accouchement étant fait là on peut
penser qu'on aura les amidales et puis
peut-être également tout le tout toute
la famille derrière et donc il y a une
forme de fidélisation au travers de de
ces éléments-là et je crois malgré tout
que depuis un grand moment les uns et
les autres ont conscience que il y a une
un élément de tarification qui pose
difficulté le le le rapport en fait état
les uns et les autres le disent
régulièrement et notamment parce que
pendant très très longtemps et bien dans
l'hospitalisation privée effectivement
la femme et l'enfant étaient confondu
enfin la femme et le bébé étaient
confondu il n'y avait pas de financement
pour le pour le nouveau-né et donc
quelque part petit à petit malgré tout
ce financement est est augmenté du côté
du nouveau-né et on peut imaginer que
les choses devraient se se stabiliser il
serait malgré tout intéressant d'avoir
dans ce domaine au-delà de la mesure
mesure des tarifs sur la base
structurelle de coût de se poser la
question de temps en temps également du
regard sur la norme parce que
incontestablement nous avons là entre
les coûts qui aujourd'hui dans la
réalité de terrain n'obéissent pas à la
norme et bien par définition des coûts
sous-évalués par rapport à une norme qui
elle est différente et donc il serait
intéressant également que à
l'occasion de l'évaluation médicale
épidémiologique qui pourrait être faite
soit également conduite des évaluations
j'allais dire plus économique à la fois
sur le caractère faisable et
pardonnez-moi le terme également
rentable au sens rentable pour la
société gestion pour la société de
l'ensemble à la fois des maisons de
naissance et des et des centres périnato
de proximité je rappelle que je n'ai
jamais vu semble-t-il ou alors cela m'a
échappé et je regrette alors de le dire
d'évaluation médico-économique sur ces
sujets et donc par la même occasion et
bien de voir quelle pourrait être
effectivement une meilleure régulation
de la
tarification via la tarification
actuelle dans le cadre des maternités je
vous remercie beaucoup merci beaucoup je
vais d'abord donner la parole au
rapporteur général puis ensuite à chacun
des sénateurs qui
s'inscrira
merci monsieur le Président je voudrais
tout d'abord remercier monsieur le
Président durlement sur la
qualité de ce rapport mais je dirais que
c'est devenu une habitude de féliciter
la Cour des comptes pour la qualité de
ces enquêtes et de ces rapports mais je
le soulligne parce qu'il est
véritablement
complet que vous avez aussi en
annexe les les
enquêtes les synthèses des enquêtes
régionales sont aussi très précieuses
pour
éclairer notre jugement c'est souvent
que je dirais au sein de cette
commission on a eu à aborder cette
question des maternités mais je souligne
je remercie la présidente Annie David
d'avoir pris cette initiative parce
qu'on voit bien que au
là des questions plus
générales
d'organisation de l'accès de l'offre de
soins et de l'accès au
soins le problème de des maternités est
un problème vraiment très particulier
euh je pense
que vous avez
d'ailleurs tout a été dit hein fait neuf
préconisations je dirais qu' doivent
servir de Brévière vous me
pardonnerez cette allusion à cette
métaphore mais je dirait pour la
ministre de la Santé euh on va avoir une
loi de santé là prochainement
euh je pense que c'est une occasion pour
y mettre un chapitre particulier ou tout
au
moins quelques tiret sur ce secteur qui
est bien parti qui est à à nos
yeux essentiel
essentiel parce que tout le monde l'a
souligné je crois le président de la
République il y a pas si longtemps que
la
démographie de la France était un
facteur
important de réussite
euh c'est vrai que on voit avec le taux
de
natalité qui est de de environ hein euh
que nous sommes les premiers en Europe
euh et que ça ne se dém pas c'est
pérenne et donc malgré la situation
économique dirons-nous euh les Français
les Françaises sont toujours
effectivement euh aujourd'hui prêtes à à
construire une famille euh avec deux
enfants alors vous notez à ce propos que
néanmoins on a un mauvais classement on
un mauvais classement en Europe qui est
celui de la mortalité
infantile la c'est vrai c'est grave 2,3
je crois pour 1000 décès mais est-ce que
il faudrait pas le mettre aussi en
rapport avec justement le nombre absolu
de naissance euh c'est bien que en
statistique on mesure effectivement par
un ratio au 1000 mais je pense qu'il est
important effectivement de souligner et
d'analyser euh comme vous le faites les
raisons pour pouvoir effectivement
modifier en quelque sorte ce mauvais
classement font
connaître exactement les raisons alors
on les a
évoqué les uns et les autres d'ailleurs
je l'ai entendu aussi bien du côté de la
FHF que du côté de la RS on soulligne
notamment
l'éloignement euh
desparturiantes des maternités comme
étant un facteur un problème facteur en
tous les cas de mortalité
euh je crois qu'il serait intéressant
d'avoir une analyse un petit peu plus
fine de cette question qui reoint qui
rejoint d'ailleurs d'autres problèmes
que vous avez soulevé
euh vous insistez notamment sur le
nombre minimal d'accouchement nécessair
pour un établissement de santé pour
qu'il puisse les assurer en toute
sécurité hein le seuil qui a été fixé
par les décrets de 98 et de 300 il n'est
pas observé partout ça pose problème
effectivement la loi et la loi mais
effectivement
euh quels sont euh les raisons on les
connaît pour la plupart hein les les
pressions notamment des élus locaux euh
nous en sommes donc on connaît
effectivement ce problème mais c'est pas
les seuls il y a aussi le problème de
l'accès et de la proximité donc de
l'éloignement que je soulignais et puis
vous proposez à ce moment-là
euh de transformer ces peut-être ces
petites unités en centre de périnatalité
qui serait adossé à un centre
hospitalier c'est peut-être une solution
tous les cas ça mériterait certainement
d'être creusé vous vous vous parlez
effectivement que ce seuil est même
peut-être trop bas alors est-ce que vous
avez une idée sur le seuil qui serait le
plus acceptable pour justement toujours
améliorer la qualité effectivement à la
fois de l'accès c'est il faut
optimiserin c'est pas simple l'accès
pour les populations aux maternités et
en même temps la qualité évidemment du
de la prise en charge et d'abaisser
effectivement le taux de mortalité voilà
en fait l'équation qui est à résoudre et
qui n'est pas simple j'ai encore une
remarque à faire du même ordre on peut
le dire c'est que vous
préconisez dans vos
remarque la
recomposition de
l'offre sur la recomposition de l'offre
vous préconisez de partir d'une carte
blanche on dit on on partirait de zéro
si on part de zéro quelle serait la
carte idéale des maternités en France je
vois bien l'intérêt d'une telle démarche
sauf que elle peut-être un peu éloignée
de la réalité et vudrait-il pas mieux
partir de la réalité pour essayer
d'adapter en quelque
sorte le en répondant aux critères
précédents à cette à cette
recomposition que vous
préconisez le dernier point que je
voudrais souligner c'est le modèle
économique vous parlez du modèle
économique qui est
défaillant et notamment ça se traduit
par la fermeture de de maternité privée
euh c'est vrai que c'était longtemps je
l'ai
entendu de la part de certaines certains
groupes que c'était un produit d'appel
en quelque sorte en terme de marketing
ça l'est peut-être un peu moins
aujourd'hui pour des raisons financières
vous les avez souligné il y a un effet
de ciseau entre les coûts et puis les
recettes et vous proposez d'améliorer le
taux d'occupation vous l'avez dit euh la
durée moyenne de séjour la
suppression de certains lits et des
moyens qui sont affectés est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est suffisant est-ce que
vous ne croyez pas qu'il y a là aussi un
problème je me tourne vers la FHF de
tarification à
l'activité tout simplement qui n'est pas
suffisamment pris en compte
la je dirais je je pense qu'on a trop
tendance
à peut-être sous-évaluer
l'importance effectivement de la
natalité en
France tout
simplement et je pense que effectivement
s'il est important de
soigner les cancers de soigner les
maladies graves il est aussi aussi très
important de pouvoir effectivement
permettre aux enfants de naître dans les
meilleures conditions donc voilà
quelques remarques que je voulais vous
faire avec quelques questions à l'appui
monsieur durlement je vais laisser la
parole à quelques sénateurs
supplémentaires puis après on vous
laissera la parole madame Génisson il y
a un sujet qui a pas du tout évoqué été
évoqué quand on parle de maternité qui
pourtant été souvent évoqué c'est les la
variabilité de taux de césarienne et ça
c'est pas du tout parce que je pense que
c'est un indicateur qui est également
intéressant pour connaître la fiabilité
et la bonne qualité de d'accueil d'un
établissement madame
meunier merci monsieur le Président
peut-être pour aller plus loin dans
cette évaluation que vous nommez
évaluation médico-financière moi
j'aimerais peut-être que nous
poursuivions monsieur le président de la
commission des affaires sociales sur des
aspects très pragmatiques et très
quantifiés combien ça coûte un un
accouchement ordinaire combien ça coûte
une césarienne enfin bon toutes ces ces
soins qui sont aussi post NATO peut-être
on pourrait avoir des éléments
pragmatiques en tout cas moi je les ai
pas et j'aimerais bien les avoir donc
voilà et puis la question mais madame
Génisson l'a posé sur les les modes de
faire des des accouchements et notamment
la question des césariennes dont on
avait beaucoup parlé à un moment qui
avait des disparités aussi bien dans les
secteurs publics que privé enfin voilà
où est-ce qu'on en est aujourd'hui merci
bien monsieur le Président je vous
laisse la la réponse r à toutes ces
questions puis nous passerons ensuite à
une deuxème
fournée merci beaucoup monsieur le le
président
d'abord
s'agissant des questions qui nous ont
été posées par Monsieur le le rapporteur
général et d'une part donc la question
de savoir
si notre mauvais classement regarde des
indicateurs de de
périnatalité peut être corrélé au fait
que nous avons une natalité
forte ce que ce que nous constatons dans
les comparaisons c'est que le pays qui
par l'importance de sa natalité est le
plus proche de nous qui est la
Grande-Bretagne a malgré tout des
indicateurs de natalité de
périnatalité qui sont sous certains
aspects meilleur que meilleur que nous
et donc ça nous amène à ça nous amène à
à à considérer que dans un environnement
démographique à peu près du même ordre
sans doute avec des problématiques
socio-économiques qui nous sont
globalement comparables il y a moyen
encore pour notre pays de faire des de
faire des progrès c'était d'ailleurs la
conviction du ministre de la Santé qui
était Bernard couchner qui était à
l'origine des décrets de
1998 qu'une meilleure organisation des
prises en charge pouvait permettre des
progrès très substantiels dans nos
indicateurs de périnatalité et
malheureusement ce que nous constatons
de ce point de vue-là et sans mestimer
du tout l'action des pouvoirs publics en
terme de
réorganisation de reconfiguration des
maternités parce que nous avons souligné
l'importance des efforts qui ont été
faits c'est que sous l'angle des
indicateurs de périnatalité les
résultats ne sont pas au rendez
les objectifs qui ont été fixés ne sont
pas au au
rendez-vous de de ce de ce de ce point
de vue-l
euh nous l'avons déjà
documenté dans le rapport public annuel
de la Cour il y a 2 ans il nous apparaît
qu'il y a une urgence à se
remobiliser sur ces résultats de
périnatalité euh qui ne sont pas bons
euh qui n'évoluent pas comme ceux de nos
voisin et qui pose donc vraiment une
question qui nous paraît tout à fait
importante pas simplement au système de
soins beaucoup d'entre vous l'ont
souligné également aux autres acteurs en
particulier au réseau des services de
protection maternelle et infantile
qui évidemment ont un rôle déterminant
dans la
qualité de la prise en charge de la
naissance au sens au sens large ça n'est
pas simplement un élément du système de
soins qui s'agisse des établissements de
santé publique ou privé ou qu'il
s'agisse des acteurs libéraux c'est
également une question qui s'intéresse
en particulier à la structuration de
l'effort de PMI et lorsque nous avons
regardé plus globalement ce sujet de la
prise en charge de la naissance dans le
cadre du rapport public annuel que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure nous avions
constaté que d'un département à
l'autre l'action de la PMI la
structuration des services de PMI et la
manière dont il prenait en compte cette
dimension de l'amélioration des
indicateurs de périnatalité pouvait être
pouvait être très
différent sur la question des seuils
d'activité euh nous ne sommes pas
médecins et donc nous ne nous prononçons
absolument pas sur ce sujet comme
disait le vieil atage
latin sousor nultra crépidable le
cordonnier ne se situe pas au-dessus de
la semelle donc nous n'entrons pas dans
un champ de compétence qui n'est pas le
nôtre ce que nous avons entendu lors des
auditions auxquelles nous avons procédé
malgré tout de la part euh euh euh des
différentes sociétés savantes euh en
matière de gynécologie obstétrique c'est
que la question euh du seuil à 300 était
une question qui méritait sans doute
d'être redocumenté ce qui nous est
apparu nous de notre point de vue c'est
que il y a autour de ces établissement
euh de 500 à 1000 accouchements
manifestement une une concentration de
difficultés une concentration de
difficulté d'une part d'ordre économique
manifestement 500000 accouchement en
l'état actuel de la
tarification ne permet absolument pas un
équilibre qui se situe plutôt à 12 et
puis c'est là que se situe
prioritairement les difficultés de
recrutement des établissements il y a
une espèce de mise en concurrence des
établissements pour le recrutement de la
ressource la plus rare uellement qui
soit qui est celle des
professionnels qui pose une question
d'ordre d'ordre d'ordre général c'est
pour ça que nous nous appelons à
réfléchir sur cette question des seuils
d'activité tout en considérant et c'est
également une question que certains
d'entre vous ont posé qu'il n'est pas
anormal en soi qu'il puisse y avoir des
situation
dérogatoire ce qui nous semble difficile
c'est quand ces situations dérogatoires
ne sont pas entouré de toutes les
conditions de sécurité possibles et
lorsque nous avons documenter la
situation de di ou la situation du sel
c'est précisément parce que continue à
fonctionner aujourd'hui des maternités
de moins de 300 accouchements dont on
sait qu'elles ne sont pas en état
d'assurer des prises en charge dans des
conditions de totale sécurité c'est ce
décalage qui nous paraît véritablement
problématique mais nous disons dans
notre rapport c'est une de nos
propositions que les
maternités qui doivent fonctionner à
titre dérogatoire doivent être donc
évidemment misisees sous conditions de
fonctionnement sécure absolu et doivent
également être mises en situation
d'équilibre financier c'est pour ça que
les dispositions que vous avez voté
prévoyant pour des des établissements
comment dirais-je d'établiss
d'aménagement du territoire des modes de
fixation des modes de financement mixte
nous paraissent particulièrement
intéressant pour certains types pour
certains types de de de
maternité pour revenir sur les
maternités les plus importantes
c'est-à-dire celles de plus de 4000
accouchements il nous semble en tout cas
c'est la
réflexion que ces maternités importantes
nous ont livré qu'elles ont besoin de
règles du jeu qui soi plus clair parce
Queau fond aujourd'hui au-delà de 2000
accouchement il n'y a pas
véritablement de mode d'organisation qui
soit
véritablement prévu elles éprouvent le
besoin d'avoir une
organisation qui soit
peut-être plus claire plus clair pour
elle plus clair aussi sans doute
peut-être au regard de l'exercice de
leur responsabilité quand nous proposons
précisément pour les maternités niveau
3 de réfléchir à
l'opportunité de l'insertion d'un
service de réanimation adulte dans ses
maternités c'est parce que dans un
certain nombre de cas au regard des
problématiques de mortalité maternelle
sur lequel notre pays n'est pas bien
placé il apparaît que ça serait
évidemment quelque chose d'utile ça
n'est possible pour autant évidemment
que s'il y a un flux de formation
suffisant d'anesthésiste réanimateur
peut-être aussi si précisément des
réorganisations accrues notamment dans
le domaine chirurgical permettent de
libérer un potentiel supplémentaire
parce que là aussi il y a une
concurrence entre de multiples services
et de multiples et de multiples euh
activités s'agissant de la problématique
des césariennes euh et des césariennes
de euh de de de de
confort nous avons cherché à analyser
dans notre rapport vous le trouverez à
la page 29 la manière dont en
particulier la Haute Autorité de Santé a
cherché précisément à lancer des actions
sur l'optimisation du recours à la
césarienne c'est une action qui a été
très puissamment relayée par les réseaux
de santé
pinato et nous constatons que comment
dirais-je dans dans un certain nombre
d'établissements la chasse à la mauvaise
indication a eu pour effet véritablement
une régulation très forte de la pratique
de la de la pratique de la césarienne
nous le documentons en particulier en ce
qui concerne l'action du réseau de santé
périnatale de Vergne
sur la la
question
de la recommandation numéro 6 donc
l'articulation en réseau villehôpital ça
nous paraît tout à fait déterminant le
Prado nous paraît une initiative
intéressante elle n'est pas la seule
initiative très souvent le Prado s'est
superposé à des initiatives
hospitalières et libérales qui étai déjà
organisées et dans un certain nombre de
cas le
Prado est intervenu de façon un peu
désorganisé
par rapport à des pratiques antérieures
c'est pour ça que nous pensons que le
Prado va plutôt dans la bonne direction
mais que la manière peut-être dont il a
été introduit n'a pas toujours été
toujours la plus la plus efficiente
voilà monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les sénataires quelques
premières réponses merci si les la FHF
ou les ARS veulent
réagir non pour l'instant tend non bon
alors je vais repasser à la parole au
sénateur en commençant par Madame Cohen
oui mais merci Monsieur le le Président
c'est sûr que les les les enquêtes qui
sont fournies par la Cour des comptes
présentent toujours un un travail
fouillé et son source d'intérêt
d'ailleurs qu'il parle des chiffres
concernant les maternités ou des fraudes
aux cotisations sociales qui qui ont
étit plus controversé dans dans nos
rangs quand il s'agissait des
entreprises mais en tout cas c'est
toujours digne d'intérêt et de réflexion
pour les sénatrices et les sénateurs que
nous sommes euh moi j'ai j'ai un certain
nombre d'interrogations sur euh les les
le rapport qui nous est présenté qui est
un un rapport qui est très orienté sur
les les chiffres et sur la rentabilité
financière de mon point de vue
euh un peu déconnecté euh de ce qu'est
un un service de santé publique et
notamment euh euh est-ce que euh les
maternités peuvent être uniquement
considéré d'un point de vue rentable
donc même si les propos de Monsieur le
Président le démon le démante ce que je
suis en train de dire en fait quand on
on voit les les phrases qui sont
utilisées dans le rapport moi j'ai j'y
vois cette orientationl alors moi la
question que je me pose c'est que quand
je vois par exemple une étude de la
adresse 2013 qui dit que le nombre des
maternités est passé
de369 en en 75 à 554 en 2008 entre 1996
et 2011 le nombre des maternités de
niveau 1 est passé de 564 à
255 moi en tant que sénatrice en tant
que femme je me demande si c'est un
progrès euh et je me demande également
tout en en appréciant d'ailleurs ce que
mon collègue a dit sur le fait que
effectiv effectivement on est on est
obligé parce que nous sommes
responsables de tenir compte des
conditions de sécurité ça c'est évident
aucun d'entre nous ici ne va le balayer
d'un revers de main mais en même temps
moi j'ai envie quand même que l'on on
aborde la question de c'est quoi la
maternité c'est pas une maladie c'est
pas pathologique la maternité or à quoi
on assiste depuis quelques années
maintenant on assiste à une
surmédicalisation je veux dire que
considérer comme progrès le
développement des maternités de niveau 3
c'est
contestable c'est contestable etuss je
ne sais pas quels experts savants ont
été auditionnés mais nous en
auditionnons nous en auditionnons nous
également des experts savants et il il
il remettent en cause cette explosion
des maternités de niveau 3 il est il est
indispensable d'avoir les deux et de ne
pas opposer de ne pas opposer les choses
il y a effectivement des grossesses à
risque qui ont besoin de maternité de
niveau 3 et il y a des des grossesses
j'allais dire banal c'est pas le mot qui
je ne sais pas quel autre mot dire
classique normal voilà ordinaire qui qui
nécessite pas et
l'accompagnement moi je crois qu'il y a
aussi à prendre en compte effectivement
la formation des professionnels et la et
l' l'accompagnement parce que quand
j'entends dire come un progrès que il y
a dans d'autres pays
européens finalement un temps de séjour
qui est moindre et un de nos collègues
nous dit comme un modèle une journée
seulement bah moi je ne considère pas ça
comme un comme un
progrès quand une femme accouche c'est
pas ça ne se fait pas en quelques
quelques minutes ou quelques heures
alors c'est certaines ont ça dépend
effectivement certaines ont besoin
peut-être de plus de temps pour se pour
ce reprend pour reprendre les choses et
cetera mais je veux dire que arrêtons de
penser que le le délai de de de séjour
parce que il serait moins important
serait un progrès et parce que cette
certaines femmes quand même minoritaires
et dont les les conditions sociales sont
quand même
àouiller peuvent au bout de quelques
jours reprendre l'activité on a vu une
célèbre ministre qui effectivement
l'avait fait mais bon c'est pas un
modèle voilà c'est pas un modèle donc
moi je pense qu'il faut faire attention
au aux critères qu'on prend qu'on prend
en compte c'est ma première remarque et
puis situer quand même le fait de ces
fermetures de ces restructurations dans
une dans une logique qui pour pour nous
au groupe CRC nuit à la politique de
santé publique c'est-à-dire c'est la loi
HPST donc qui est quand même branché sur
des fermetures des regroupements
d'établissements et là je rejoins sur
une autre partie ce que notre rapporteur
général a dit sur est-ce que la la la la
T2A est
appropriée aux activités si je puis dire
de la de de la maternité euh la deuxième
la dernière chose que je que je voudrais
dire aussi et qui m'a qui m'a choqué en
tout cas qui qui pose des questions qui
me pose des questions c'est le temps
d'accès médian de 17 minutes alors
certes c'est une moyenne mais moi j'ai
eu l'occasion d'auditionner Monsieur
Emmanuel vigneron qui est géographe sur
les inégalités territoriales quand on a
dû présenter notre PPL concernant le le
le moratoire contre les fermetures
d'établissements et les regroupements
d'établissements et lui il met en garde
sur des des endroits alors ça peut être
effectivement géographiquement dans dans
les zones de montagne et là je les
serait ma collègue Annie David peut-être
donner des des éléments plus précis mais
pas que c'est pas seulement les zones
rurales et les zones montagneus où on
dépasse les 17 minutes c'est aussi les
zones denses avec avec des des des
embouteillages et des accès des fois qui
sont extrêmement périlleux pour une
femme qui qui qui doit accoucher donc
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire de de prendre
enfin moi je trouve que c'est pas c'est
pas c'est pas un critère qui me semble
pertinent c'est un indicateur
et après prendre référence donc au
niveau européen moi je ne sais pas
si ça doit nous nous entraîner à comment
dirais-je réduire les coûts réduire les
temps et cetera alors que peut-être que
c'est au niveau de notre système
d'organisation qu'il faudrait tirer des
enseignements pour l'ensemble de de
l'EUR enfin la la dernière chose qui me
semble qui me pose problème moi c'est
dans les dans les précon isationtion euh
c'est la préconisation numéro 2 et la
préconisation numéro
9 parce que moi j'ai entendu de nombreux
professionnels effectivement défendre
des maternnité de proximité avec des des
nombres d'accouchements qui étaient
limite au au seuil de de 300 alors si je
pense qu'il faut prendre en compte les
questions de sécurité je pense qu'il
faut qu'on ait un peu d'imagination euh
pour essayer de voir comment on peut
optimiser des équipes qui pourraient
être des équipes qui se qui se déplac
mais pas
euh prendre comme décision le fait de
fermer ses maternité donc essayz
peut-être de de de travailler sur des
des équipes qui pourraient se déplacer
sur des pour que les les les
professionnels puissent effectivement
avoir dans leur pratique un nombre
d'accouchements qui leur permettent
d'avoir un un un savoir-faire euh
important mais ne pas fermer des
maternités puisque euh euh je pense que
euh on on prend le problème à l'envers
et enfin mon dernier mot je je veux
attirer votre attention sur le fait que
parfois on se sert des arguments de
sécurité pour fermer des maternités je
pense à d'ourdan qui d'ailleurs a été
réouverte depuis et je pense aux menaces
qui qui pèsent sur la maternité des
Lilas et qui pourtant est tellement
symbolique dans la façon de de faire non
seulement de au niveau des
d'accouchement et mais également
l'accompagnement des mères et
l'accompagnement des enfants monsieur
forisser
pardon merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président de la 6e chambre
permettez-moi de vous dire que ce
rapport est précieux c'est un outil
d'aide à la décision pour moi ainsi que
tous les éléments qui ont été portés à
ma connaissance alors il est vrai que
chacun d'entre nous en tant que sénateur
nous avons un prisme personnel qui est
notre vécu du quotidien en ce qui me
concerne pour que les choses soient
claires j'ai été euh premier
vice-président du conseil général du
Rône alors que le président était garde
des saau vous vous doutez bien donc la
responsabilité de faire fonctionner un
département important aujourd'hui je
suis aussi parmi les élus fondateurs de
la métropole et je partage le souci de
mes collègu quand il nous parle en
quelque sorte de gestion de territoire
et pour avoir gérer à la fois des
territoires ruraux et des territoires
densifiés pour
moi la l'arrivée au monde d'un être
humain la
naissance jusqu'à la fin de sa vie c'est
un problème global de santé publique et
comme certaines de mes collègues l'ont
dit la maternité la grossesse c'est pas
une maladie et c'est ça ne devrait plus
être un accident non plus donc je crois
que là on rentre à la fois dans les
problématiques de prévention comme l'a
très bien dit notre rapporteur général
aussi je partage complètement ses
préoccupations pour moi la première
question qui se pose on est passé dans
une organisation globale de la santé où
on parlait des centres médicaux-sociaux
qui aujourd'hui ont disparu on a
longtemps eu les généralistes qui
étaient sur la enfin on disparu pas
complètement mais c'est plus la même
formulation on avait aussi une certaine
confiance dans les généralistes qui
avaient une place qui aujourd'hui il se
pose beaucoup des questions sur la
médecine de proximité je crois qu'il est
nécessaire de retisser une nouvelle
toile comme cela elle a été bien dit de
manière à avoir en bien entendu en
arrière-penser vos recommandations qui
sont des préoccupations que nous avons
déjà découvert au niveau local qui
conforent dans les impressions que nous
avions par des certitudes alors pour moi
ces
recommandations il me semble que on ne
peut pas les mettre en hiérarchie dans
l'ordre qu'elles ont été posées pour moi
la la première priorité ça serait le
numéro 3 mieux organisé la prise en
charge des grossesses à risque et cetera
parce que là on parle de prévention
ensuite le numéro 6 qui est renforcer le
suivi des femmes enceintes tout
particulièrement en situation de
précarité pour être aussi maèire d'une
commune de banlieu je peux vous dire que
là on a un travail important et puis en
numéro 3 ça serait le 7 qui serait de
définir un schéma C d'organisation à
moyen terme des maternités c'est-à-dire
la toile de couverture du territoire ou
bien entendu pour moi et c'est important
la médecine libérale doit avoir toute sa
place parce qu'aujourd'hui on assiste
quand même à un approvvissement de la
considération de la médecine libérale
qui fait que regarder pour les problèmes
de garde de médecin pour différents
problèmes de couverture du territoire la
prévention ne peut être que global dans
la santé on peut pas avoir des
spécialistes dans toutes les communes de
ça c'est certain par contre il y a cette
hiérarchie qui est importante à
redéfinir qui à mon avis est vraiment à
remettre en cause dans sa globalité
parce que quand on me parle notamment
des normes à respecter moi je parlerai
des capacité qu'on a respecté ces normes
parce qu'effectivement que ça soit dans
une maternité ou dans un épad la la
problématique est la même on se retrouve
avec nos partenaires les financeurs ceux
qui a la la responsabilité de la qualité
et l'élu qui est au milieu doit arbitrer
des choix budgétaires donc il faut faire
très attention il mais je ne veux pas
dire que l'élu doit être déloigné de ses
responsabilités j'ai pris la
responsabilité de fermer une clinique d'
faire un arrêté de fermeture clinique
avec les pressions et les conséquences
que que vous savez sur un territoire et
ça aboutit ensuite 5 ans après une
clinique donc j'avz quand même gagné
mais quand vous êtes là vous êtes quand
même contraint par par des différents
partenaires donc je crois qu'aujourd'hui
il faudrait peut-être revisiter cette
normalité qu'on veut mettre en norme
idéale mais qu'on n'a pas la capacité de
tenir compte tenu de l'état économique
de la
France merci Madame
David merci
Président si je je peux m'associer en
effet au félicitations et sur la qualité
des présentations je n'en reste pas
moins toujours un petit peu comment dire
agacé peut-être ou contrarié je ne sais
pas quel terme employé mais par le fait
que en effet l'aspect est toujours euh
principalement en tout cas financier et
là bien évidemment nous avons un rapport
de de la Cour des comptes donc forcément
nous avons un rapport financier mais il
me semble que les chiffres on peut aussi
les faire parler avec un peu plus de
comment dire un peu plus de prise en
compte du sujet abordé et en
l'occurrence la maternité ça a été dit
par différents orateurs avant moi mais
les maternités sont quand même un sujet
qui revête une certaine humanité et il
me semble que parfois dans les chiffres
quand on quand on les on les exploite et
bien on n'arrive pas à ressentir
justement cet aspect un peu humain du
sujet donc je n'ai pas vraiment de de
questions sur sur l'ensemble des
présentations je je les partage
évidemment je partage le soucis finan ci
néanmoins qu'il faut garder en tête
toujours lorsqu'il s'agit de des
dépenses de santé publique je voudrais
juste revenir sur la la la durée la
distance et je rejoins ce que disait ma
collègue Laurence Cohen et notre
collègue Claude ha également sur les
fameuses 17 minutes médianes je crois
qu'il faut quand même bien se rendre
compte que ces 17 minutes médianes sont
en effet un temps moyen d'accès à une
maternité mais que dans certains
endroits c'est bien plus long pour acc
d' une maternité et surtout ce qu'il
faut regarder je crois c'est que dans
les dernières années le temps a augmenté
d'après l'étude de de la de la Darès qui
date un petit peu maintenant qui date de
2011 mais dans une cinquantaine de
départements quand même le temps d'accès
à augmenté plutôt que diminuer dans une
vingtaine d'entre eux en effet le temps
a diminué et dans une autre vingtaine à
peu près le temps est resté stable mais
quand même dans une cinquantaine de
départements le temps a augmenté et
parfois augmenté d'une manière très
importante parce que les fermetures de
maternité de proximité ont fait que et
bien on se retrouvait de plus en plus
éloigné des maternité de de niveau 3
c'est vrai et là aussi je m'interroge y
a-t-il nécessité à ce qu'il y ait un
développement
important des maternité de niveau 3
alors qu'on le voit bien et d'ailleurs
le président duurlement l'a rappelé
lui-même que de plus en plus de femmes
souhaitent souhaiteraiit en tout cas
accoucher dans des dans des conditions
un peu plus naturelles plutôt que
surmédicalisé donc peut-être pe-être
qu'il y a à s'interroger aussi sur cet
acharnement à vouloir faire des
maternités de niveau 3 alors que
peut-être ça coûterait sans doute en
plus moins cher mais peut-être qu'on
pourrait maintenir des maternités un peu
plus de proximité et de niveau 2
pourquoi pas puisque c'est cette
difficulté cette ces fermetures de de
maternité ont aussi amené quand même une
diminution du du nombre de lits donc
alors qu'il y a une augmentation du
nombre de naissance il y a une
diminution du nombre de lit si au moins
ces fermetures de maternité n'avaient
pas amené à une diminution du nombre de
lits mais là en plus de ça il y a donc
une une diminution du du nombre de lit
et on parle beaucoup du taux
d'occupation mais en même temps dans
certains pays ça voisine 3 jours en
France on est encore à 4 jours2 nous
avez-vous dit Monsieur durlement voilà
moi je pense que en effet un
accouchement c'est le moment de
l'accouchement mais c'est aussi l'après
accouchement quand une femme rentre à
son domicile comment est-elle préparée
pour rentrer à son domicile quelle
quelle condition de vie elle va trouver
à son domicile toutes les femmes n'ont
pas les mêmes conditions de vie
lorsqu'elle retourne à leur à leur
domicile certaines n'ont pas d'autres
enfants certaines en ont déjà d'autres
ont un mari qui pourra les les aider
mais parfois au contraire les maris non
seulement ne les aideront pas mais les
mettront peut-être aussi à rue
d'épreuves toutes ces choseslà c'est à
prendre en considération avant de dire
un taux moyen de de de maintien enfin de
de séjour d'une femme dans une maternité
donc je pense Queen effet la l'étude
épidémiologique qui est demandée je
pense qu'elle a tout son intérêt mais si
elle est comme le disait euh Madame la
Directrice Générale euh comme si si elle
prend en compte bien évidemment l'aspect
financier mais aussi euh l'aspect euh
médical même si on est bien tous
d'accord une grossesse n'est pas une
maladie mais en attendant il y a aussi
ces critères-là à à à prendre en compte
si on veut véritablement euh apporter
une réponse à à à à la problématique des
maternités parce que je crois aussi que
les maternités font partie de
l'aménagement de nos territoires notre
collègue parlait à l'instant de du texte
en discussion mais si on veut en effet
que dans nos territoires et bien des des
des familles puissent encore y vivre il
faudra pas retirer tout ce qui peut
faire que la vie continue à être
présente dans nos territoires et fermer
tous ces toutes ces structures parce que
elles auraient un coût financier trop
important je pense que c'est pas
forcément rendre la rendre enfin donner
une une chance à notre pays de de de
maintenir sa qualité de vie dans tous
les territoires voilà monsieur le
Président ce n'était pas vraiment des
questions
merci euh avant de passer la parole à à
à madame procacia je voudrais quand même
juste dire que pour pour prendre la
défense un petit peu d'acc cour que moi
j'ai eu le rapport aussi j'ai vraiment
pas le sentiment que ce soit un rapport
financier ou un rapport sur le
financement de la sécurité sociale ou
sur un j'ai plutôt de la sécurité
sociale de la maternité j'ai plutôt
l'impression que c'éit un rapport sur le
sous-financi
des maternités que qui rapport sur le
surfinancement et et moi j'ai plutôt vu
beaucoup de préconisations sur la
sécurité plus que sur le financement de
la maternité enfin bon monsieur durement
est assez grand pour se défendre tout
seul je passé la parole à Madame
procassia puis ensuite il y aura
monsieur Chassin puis ensuite il y aura
la Fédération hospitalière et nous
aurons terminé le tour de ceux qui
souhaitent prendre la
parole merci je voudrais remercier à la
fois monsieur le Président et la Cour
des comptes parce que quand on est n'est
pas du tout impliqué et spécialiste de
ce secteur je trouve que l'audition de
ce matin personnellement m'a appris
beaucoup de beaucoup de choses
euh vous je voudrais poser simplement
deux questions une sur les maternités de
plus de 4000 euh hormis celle de
matmudzu qui est
célèbre même pour les n spécialistes
j'aimerais savoir quels sont les autres
grosses maternités si elles se situe
aussi s'il y en a d'autres aussi qui
sont en outreem ou si c'est tout dans
des grandes villes euh la deuxème
question concerne la mortalité néonatale
et la
proposition numéro 5 euh est-ce que la
natalité néoatale s'est vraiment
dégradée ces dernières années ou en tout
cas
depuis les dispositions qui se sont
appliquées euh est-ce que il y a a une
cartographie de la mortalité néonatale
soit selon des régions particulières euh
soit selon des
des des types de maternité c'était les
deux questions merci merci Monsieur
Chassin oui oui monsieur le Président je
crois que tout a été dit je vais être
assez bref
l'accouchement est bien sûr quelque
chose de naturel dans l'immense majorité
ça a été vu ça se passe bien mais même
lorsqu'il n'y a pas une grossesse à
risque effectivement il peut y avoir des
urgences à prendre en charge extrêmement
rapidement donc dans ce rapport on voit
que effectivement on n'est pas classé
dans les premiers de pour la la prise en
charge notamment de
périnatalité et la prise en charge de de
la de la maman et je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec ce qui est préconisé dans
ces neuf recommandations je voudrais en
féliciter particulièrement les auteurs
de de ce rapport qui est
particulièrement
pertinent c'est uniquement effectivement
et c'est possible d'appliquer ce ce
rapport ça va entraîner une amélioration
de la sécurité et notamment la prise en
charge de mieux de grossesse à risque
les les petites maternités il est il est
pas dit dans ce rapport qu'il faut il
faut qu'elle soit fermée il est
simplement dit que pour améliorer et
bien il faut y apporter un financement
plus important adéquate et et être en
réseau avec des équipes mais je
voudrais dire que lorsqu'il y a une
urgence
renouvelée dire que lorsqu'il y a une
urgence pendant l'accouchement il faut
intervenir très rapidement et c'est le
but effectivement de de ce rapport pour
qu'il est moins de
décès le problème que je voudrais
aborder qui n'a pas été abordé c'est le
nombre de praticien dans l'avenir
le profession de gynécoobstétricien est
une profession compliquée difficile au
niveau des des horaires les jeunes
médecins on voit bien
que c'est pas la la la profession qu'ils
vont prendre d'emblé donc ce qui a été
dit par monsieur le rapporteur
de d'avoir une des préconisations au
niveau d'une région au niveau des CHU
pour essayer de qu'il y ait davantage de
jeunes qui s'orientent vers cette
filière ça c'est aussi quelque chose qui
me paraît très
extrêmement primordial et aussi je
regrette que on on reste toujours avec
un numérus closus très bas et dans cette
filière on va encore avoir besoin de
plus de médecins de Ben de pays
étrangers rouani ou ou autres et je
regrette qu'on qu'on maintienne un
numérus closus très bas pour la médecine
générale pour la médecine pour
l'obstétrique et aussi pour la la
pédiatrie puisque dans l'avenir on va
avoir de très gros problèmes à ce niveau
merci Madame Augustin
non simplement insister sur sur le fait
et je crois que le le rapport on fait
état de l'intérêt qu'il y aurait
effectivement à faire une évaluation au
au plus juste et au plus serré de
l'ensemble ou du moins tenter de les
trouver je sais que les choses sont
compliquées mais tenter toutefois de les
trouver pour pour essayer de savoir
quels sont les éléments qui peuvent
induire ces indicateurs là où se trouvve
les difficultés là où nous avons encore
des progrès à faire est en amont au
cours de l'hospitalisation ou en aval
sous une forme ou sous une autre car en
fin de compte cela pourrait nous
permettre effectivement une vision comme
le dit ce rapport très global et donc je
reviens sur l'intérêt d'une analyse
épidémiologique sur l'intérêt des
pratique médical et donc d'une analyse
sur la réalité des pratiques médicales
aujourd'hui et enfin sur une évaluation
médico-économique je dis bien
médico-économique et pas uniquement
médical de chacune des structures avant
de se dire qu'il faut faire des choix
qui sont des choix de telle ou telle
nature bien monsieur durlement je vais
vous laisser le soin de de conclure je
voudrais juste si vous me le permettez
avant rebondir sur ce qu'a dit Monsieur
caaher sur l'évolution des mentalités
des médecins les médecins de plus en
plus souhaitent ne plus travailler seul
dans leur coin comme ça se faisait
encore il y a 30 ans en arrière mais
travailler en équipe et dans des équipes
extrêmement structurées extrêmement
fortes extrêmement puissantes avec des
plateaux techniques à côté bien
structurés vous ne trouverez plus de
gynécologue ou d'obstétricien qui
acceptent d'aller travailler dans un
hôpital sans qu'il y ait à côté un
chirurgien un anesthésiste un plateau
technique pour l'aider au cas où il en a
besoin pareil pour les né la
néonatologie ou la ou les pédiatres ils
ne travailleront plus dans leur coin
tout seul c'est fini ça ce ce
problème-là est réglé d'une manière
définitive et on le comprend d'autant
mieux lorsqu'on regarde l'évolution et
l'augmentation considérable des
assurances qui sont demandées d'une
manière systématique chaque année il
suffit de pour ça de de de contacter
ensuite les syndicats de médecins de
leur demander leur avis et vous verrez
que les médecins veulent travailler en
groupe avec des professionnels qui sont
formés à côté d'eux monsieur Durand je
vous laisse le soin de
conclure merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président je voudrais revenir d'un mot
sur l'approche qui a été la nôtre
qui n'a pas été une approche financière
même si il n'étonnera personne que les
problématiques financières ce toujours
un un regard g de la cour nous nous
sommes situés en réalité par rapport aux
objectifs de la politique
publique qui est celle de l'organisation
des maternités en
fonction des indicateurs mêmes qui
avaient été fixés par le gouvernement et
donc nous avons fait une sorte
d'évaluation de politique publiqu à
partir de cette enquête de terrain pour
voir si les résultats attendus était ou
non présent et ce que nous avons
constaté c'est précisément qu'on regard
des indicateurs de santé publique les
résultats espérés n'étaient pas présents
au moins à hauteur de ce que les
pouvoirs publics avait
souhaité et c'est pour nous la
considération principale c'est cette
considération
principale qui explique aussi nos
recommandations l'ordre de nos
recommandations n'est pas un ordre de
priorité c'est simplement l'ordre dans
lequel en fonction de nos développements
et de des différents chapitres de ce
rapport ces recommandations apparaissent
cela
étant il nous semble bien que la
recommandation principale est bien celle
que qui figure en numéro 1 c'està dire
la question des enquêtes
épidémiologiques et au fond la nécessité
de faire un point fixe 15 ans 16 ans
après les décrets de
1998 pour mieux documenter euh un
certain nombre de situations ce qui nous
a beaucoup frappé c'est que nous avons
trouvé très peu de littérature
scientifique sur ces sujets étonnamment
peu de littérature scientifique sur ces
sujets euh et c'est quelque chose qui
nous paraît très préoccupant comment
peut-il y avoir un pilotage collectif
euh d'un sujet aussi important que
celui-là sans qu'il y ait euh les
éclairages suffisants alors bien
évidemment chaque agence euh en fonction
de l'expertise qu'elle peut convoquer se
fait euh une idée euh de ce qui est à
l'œuvre de la manière dont euh les
choses se passe de la manière dont on
peut euh anticiper sur un certain nombre
d'évolutions mais nous somes qu'il est
de la responsabilité majeur des pouvoirs
publics que d'éclairer euh précisément
les choix et les décisions d'abord sous
un angle de santé publique et
aujourd'hui notre constat c'est celui
d'un défaut complet de ce point de
vue-là nous avons scruté la
littérature nous n'avons rien trouvé ce
que nous avons ramené dans nos filets
figure dans ce rapport il n'y a rien
d'autre et c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui nous paraît euh grave deuxième point
nous sommes parfaitement conscients de
la dialectique entre la sécurité et la
proximité et vous avez noté que nous ne
ça a été d'ailleurs souligné par d'entre
vous nous ne proposons pas la fermeture
abrupte de l'ensemble des petites
maternités de notre pays nous disons que
la responsabilité des pouvoirs publics
c'est de ne les laisser fonctionner qu'à
ISO conditions de sécurité par rapport à
des maternités plus importantes sécurité
pour les femmes sécurité pour pour les
enfants or dans un certain nombre de cas
ça n'est pas ce que nous avons constaté
nous n'avons pas regardé les 544
maternités de notre pays pour savoir
s'il convenait d'enfermer certaines ou
de ne pas
enfermer d'autres ça n'est pas notre
responsabilité mais nous avons travaillé
dans le temps même où les pouvoirs
publics ont été amené dans l'urgence à
fermer la maternité
d'orez le sujet du des conditions de
fonctionnement de la maternité d'orèse
n'était
ignoré ces conditions de fonctionnement
déficient n'était ignoré de personne il
y a dans la procrastination des
décisions eu des conséquences au moins
pour une femme et ça nous paraît
important de le souligner on peut faire
fonctionner titre dérogatoire toute
structure dès lors que on met en place
les conditions de sécurité le trésor de
l'hôpital
euh le trésor de notre système de soins
c'est la confiance des patients si cette
confiance des patients est démentie
alors c'est tout ce que notre République
a construit autour de son organisation
de soins qui est mise en difficulté
j'allais dire qui est compromis et
remise en cause ce trésor de la
confiance c'est un trésor récent notre
système hospitalier a été jusque à la
fin des années
50 le lieu de prise en charge des plus
pauvres et en réalité moins dans des
conditions médicales que dans des
conditions d'accueil social ce qui s'est
construit avec la 5e République pour
lesqueles l'hôpital et en particulier
l'hôpital public a été ce qui a été
l'école publique à la 3e république est
quelque chose de tout à fait majeur
c'est un dispositif qui a créé de la
confiance si cette confiance n'est plus
là alors c'est l'ensemble du dispositif
euh qui si vous me passez l'expression
euh est mise en risque c'est pour ça que
nous insistons sur ces problématiques de
sécurité qui nous paraissent majeur bien
dans euh ces problématiques bien sûr
nous évoquons les problématiques de
financement mais comme cela a été dit
euh par vous-même monsieur le Président
nous évoquons des problématiques de
sous-financement le coût d'un
accouchement normal tel qu'il est
facturé par un établissement de santé
les données euh figurent dans le rapport
c'est 2435 € au titre de l'accouchement
de la femme si j'ose dire si ajoute 931
€ au titre de la prise en charge du
nouveau né pendant les quelques jours où
il est présent à la maternité ce que
nous constatons c'est que ces tarifs à
partir de d'une étude que nous avons
faite entre les tarifs tels qu'ils sont
fixé par les pouvoirs publics et la
réalité des coûts tel qu'elle résulte
euh de l'étude nationale comparative des
coûts c'est qu'il y a une
sousvalorisation des tarif par rapport à
la réalité des coûts elle varie euh
selon les situations mais elle est
toujours net il nous semble que cela
appelle une réflexion de la part des
pouvoirs publics cette réflexion elle ne
peut pas se déconnecter non plus des
conditions d'efficience du
fonctionnement des maternités quand nous
parlons de durée moyenne de séjour quand
nous parlons d'inadéquation des taux
d'occupation nous n'en parlons pas sous
l'angle strictement financier mais au
regard de ce que nous disent les
professionnels de la santé eux-mêmes de
ce qui de leur point de vue leur paraît
très pertinent monsieur caher au titre
de la Fédération hospitalière de France
l'a rappelé dans son intervention
liminire il y a des progrès possibles
sans en quoi que ce soit compromettre la
qualité des soins et la prise en charge
des femmes je crois que c'est quelque
chose qui est important que de continuer
à progresser et de mettre en place
évidemment les outils nécessaires c'est
pour ça que nous insistons sur le suivi
post-natal notre pays a fait un effort
considérable sur le suivi prénatal il
est encore insuffisant au regard en
particulier des population précaire mais
le suivi post-natal nous paraît
effectivement mérit
des efforts des efforts euh
renforcés voilà ce que je voulais
rappeler très euh fortement sur notre
approche ça n'est pas une approche
financière c'est une approche
d'évaluation d'une politique publique
particulière en fonction des objectifs
que les pouvoirs publics lui ont fixés
et il n'appartient pas à la cour de
substituer à ces objectifs d'autres
objectifs la Cour n'est certainement pas
là pour fixer des objectifs de santé
publique à la place des pouvoirs publics
c'est leur responsabilité évidemment de
le faire la mission que vous nous avez
confié c'est d'essayer de mesurer
quelques années après où on en est de
l'atteintte de ces objectif ce que nous
constatons c'est qu'ils n'ont pas été
atteints et de ce point de vue-là quels
que soient les efforts des uns et des
autres et nous soulignons les
considérables efforts de réorganisation
qui ont été faits euh ça n'est pas un
résultat satisfaisant nous ne
préconisons pas de ce point de vue-là
euh euh que l'ensemble du système des
maternités soit inspiré par les
maternités de niveau 3 nous disons
exactement le contraire nous disons que
la structuration euh par niveau des
types de prise en charge euh s'est
déformé et c'est anormalement déformé
c'est anormalement déformé euh au
détriment des maternités de niveau 1 euh
et au Bénéfic de maternité de niveau 2
et de maternité niveau 3 qui du coup
peine à exercer la compétence propre et
spécifique que les textes leur confient
et c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
appelons véritablement à une réflexion
sur la structuration des
maternités en en niveau cette
structuration des des maternités en
niveau nous semble poser de graves
difficultés de notre pays et ce que nous
voyons euh c'est que compte tenu des
évolutions à la fois sociologiques qui
étaient rappelé par Monsieur Cahet de la
pénurie démographique qui est en train
de se dessiner c'est le risque que cette
aspiration se poursuivent et que elles
se traduisent par le fait que les
territoires soient vidés de leurs
substances euh c'est-à-dire que les
professionnels de la naissance qui vont
être dans la période qui s'ouvre de plus
en plus rare se retrouvent tous dans ces
grands établissements au détriment des
plus petits qui ne pourront que que que
fermer c'est la raison pour laquelle au
fond 15 ans après les décrets de
1998 nous appelons à faire un point
fixe il faut prendre la mesure de tout
ce qui a été
fait faire le constat du point auquel
nous sommes aujourd'hui arrivés et sur
ces baseslà définir un projet d'ensemble
il nous semble que les agences
régionales de de santé qui sont à
l'œuvre sur le terrain ont besoin
véritablement de cette toile de fond ils
ont besoin d'être éclairés au-delà de
l'action quotidienne au-delà de la
prévision qu'ils font
d'organisation de leur territoire de
cette vision large et prospective qui
nous semble faire défaut aujourd'hui et
qui évidemment ne peut s'élaborer qu'à
partir d'une vision
épidémiologique très bien merci beaucoup
merci à vous tous le rapport donc sera
publié dès la semaine prochaine sous la
signature du rapporteur général avec les
observations faites par les uns et par
les autres et vous pourrez comme ça
ensuite vous nourrir de celui-ci pour
faire des projets futur voilà pour cette
audition de la commission des affaires
sociales du Sénat sur l'assurance Matern
dans un climat très respectueux les
sénateurs et les personnes auditionnées
sont revenus sur plusieurs thèmes clés à
ce sujet par exemple la durée
d'hospitalisation suite à un
accouchement elle est de 4 jours en
moyenne en France c'est plus que le
reste de l'OCDE où la moyenne est de 3
jours voilà une piste d'économie parmi
d'autres mais les sénateurs ont bien
insisté sur le fait qu'il fallait
maintenir un service de proximité et
équitable sur l'ensemble du territoire
vous pouvez toujours voir et revoir
toutes nos auditions sur le site
publsenat.fr très bonne journée à vous
sur les chaînes
parlementaires